Have you ever wondered whether you
should be using a comma or a semicolon?
The truth is, it doesn't matter. And
worrying about writing rules like that
will only hold you back from what really
counts, which is writing sentences that
capture the minds and hearts of your
readers. So, in this video, I'm going to
show you why focusing on grammar is
wrecking your sentences, the thing that
you need to focus on instead, and the
three simple writing exercises that my
writing students practice daily to write
better sentences in any style, whether
academic, creative, social, or
professional. But, don't just take my
word for it. Here's one of the greatest
writers of the 21st century explaining
exactly how he writes such powerful
sentences. Don DeLillo told The Paris
Review that the basic work of being a
writer is built around the sentence.
This is what I mean when I call myself a
writer. I construct sentences. There's a
rhythm I hear that drives me through the
sentence, and the words typed have a
sculptural quality. This approach to
writing by working at the sentence level
is exactly what led Don DeLillo to
develop this genius writing technique
that I've never seen anyone else talk
about before. And if you want to start
practicing it today, then I've left a
free practice sheet for you down below
the like button. But, before we start
practicing, I need to tell you about the
most important thing that writers should
be focusing on instead. And funny
enough, this lesson didn't come from a
fellow writer, but from a friend of mine
who's actually a professional painter,
which is a pretty cool job. So, one day
I asked him, "How did you become a
painter? Were you born with it? Were you
inspired by some masterpiece? Have you
always dreamed of having your work hung
in a gallery?" And it was funny. He was
painting at the time, and he kind of
paused and looked up from his canvas and
said, "I just like the smell of paint."
I had to think about that for a second,
but then it clicked. To become a
painter, you don't start with some grand
vision of hanging your masterpiece in
the Louvre. You start with a love for
the raw material, the paint. And it's
the same for writers. You don't become a
writer by wanting to be one. You become
a writer because you love the basic
material. Now, for painters, that's
paint. So, for writers, it must be
words, right? Well, not quite. You see,
words of expect um make can't sense and
stack just to you bunch together them
any. Oh, I'm sorry. What I meant to say
was, you can't just stack a bunch of
words together and expect them to make
any sense. It's the relationships
between the words that creates meaning.
So, if you like words, then go read a
dictionary. But, if you want to be a
writer, then it's time to get obsessed
with sentences. Some writers I know keep
lists of words that they come across,
but they would be much better off
keeping lists of sentences that stand
out to them. Almost like a bird watcher,
you should be on the lookout in your
reading for any sentences with new or
startling patterns. Keep track of them
and start to get curious about them.
Now, I know what you're thinking. Isn't
this just an English professor's sneaky
way of trying to get me interested in
grammar? Come on, tell the truth. Is
this broccoli in my ice cream? Well, no.
Au contraire, mon frère. Seriously, when
it comes to writing a great sentence,
grammar is completely beside the point.
Think about it this way. If I asked you
to name the best meal that you ever had,
what would it be? Take a second here to
think about that meal. What stands out?
What do you remember? For me, it was the
dinner that I had on the last night of a
trip that I took to Norway in a town
called Bergen. So, I was following the
advice of an old guidebook. So, I
started at this really cozy pub where I
met some friendly locals, and honestly,
I could have stayed there all night.
But, the guidebook promised this
incredible restaurant on the top floor
of a nearby hotel. So, eventually, I was
feeling excited and a little bit tipsy,
so I left the pub and headed over to the
hotel. But, when I got there, I found
out that the restaurant had been
replaced by a sushi spot, which is not
exactly what I was craving after all the
fresh seafood that I eat here in Korea.
So, I was a little bit disappointed, and
I struck up a conversation with the
hotel receptionist. Told him about my
situation, and he got really excited. He
said that he knew the perfect place for
authentic Norwegian cuisine. So, he made
one quick phone call and a few minutes
later he scored me a reservation at this
hidden gem, this tiny little restaurant
around the corner. Now, of course,
everyone's answer will be different
here, but more than likely your answer
to this question would be more or less
the same. You'd probably tell me the
time, the place, who you were with, and
when you ate it. You probably wouldn't
think to mention the ingredients, the
utensils, the cooking techniques that
were used to prepare the meal. Come to
think about it, I hardly even remember
the exact dishes that I ate that night,
except for the reindeer. I remember
that. You Norwegians, I must admit, you
cook a fine reindeer. The point is that,
yes, without those ingredients, the meal
would not exist, but those are not the
things that made the meal exceptional.
And it's the same thing with great
sentences. Sure, grammar and vocabulary
are the necessary ingredients, but you
can't write a great sentence by
following a recipe. And to prove to you
that even a bad sentence can be
considered great in the right context,
listen to this. All right, so what
happened was I had included this uh
sound clip of a Beatles cover song.
Anyway, the point was that it was a good
song by the Beatles, "Hey Jude," but the
band played it badly. Problem is, when I
uploaded it, I got a copyright strike.
So, I guess you're going to have to take
my word for it here.
That's bad. It's so bad it's good. This
is a cover of the song "Hey Jude." It
appeared on a radio show called The
Annoying Music Show. These songs stink.
They're objectively bad. They break all
the laws of music composition, but
they're also great. And the thing that
makes bad music great is not the notes
and the harmony. It's the way they work
against the context to achieve their
intended effect. The point of playing
these covers is not to enjoy them as
music, but to create a clash in your
mind. And that clash is really funny,
which works perfectly for the annoying
music show. Writing works the same way.
Great sentences are successful
sentences. They achieve their intended
effect, and they match the readers
expectations. Readers don't read in
order to admire grammar. They read
because they want to better understand
the world, and great sentences are great
because they open a window onto the
world, showing the reader something true
and beautiful that they had never seen
before. And if that's true, that great
sentences open a window onto the world,
then all this rule-based writing advice
that we find out there is like a complex
set of IKEA instructions for how to
build the window frame. When it comes to
writing great sentences, grammar is
completely beside the point. So, when
you're writing, instead of focusing on
grammar, ask yourself, "What am I trying
to do with this sentence? What do I want
the reader to see?" Speaking of music,
tell me if you've heard this one before.
There was this musician in New York who
was looking for directions to a famous
music hall, and so he stops a lady on
the street and asks, "Excuse me, how do
I get to Carnegie Hall?" And the woman
says, "Young man, you have to practice,
practice, practice." I always thought it
was easier to be a musician than a
writer. Musicians don't need to be
creative geniuses every day. They can
just show up and practice the scales.
But writers, we don't have scales. We
just have to sit there with a blank
page. But what if writers actually do
have scales? How would that transform
your writing practice? If you're not
writing because you feel like you have
to be totally inspired every time you
sit down to write, then you've got to
try out this writing practice. Here is a
famous sentence that means absolutely
nothing.
Colorless green ideas sleep furiously.
This sentence comes from the linguist
Noam Chomsky, who used it as an example
of a sentence that is perfectly
grammatical, but total nonsense. It's
like a vase without any flowers in it.
It's grammatical because it has the
right kinds of words in the right order,
but of course it's nonsense because
well, it doesn't really mean anything.
It doesn't make sense for ideas to be
green or for green ideas to be colorless
and ideas don't sleep so they certainly
can't sleep furiously. Still, writers
would be better off practicing writing
nonsense sentences like this than the
following. Furiously sleep ideas green
colorless. Those words are all flowers,
no vase. Each word means something, but
they have no relationship with each
other, no structure holding them
together and we can't learn anything
from writing sentences like this. If you
want to practice writing great
sentences, then it's better to focus on
form, not content, structure, not
meaning. So, if you want to practice the
scales, then it's time to play Mad Libs.
No, I'm not talking about those Mad
Libs. Mad Libs is that classic word game
that we used to play as kids. You know
the one where someone asks you to name a
random animal, a verb, or a color
without giving any context and then they
plug all those words into the blank
spaces of a pre-written story and the
result is that you get a brand new
story, which is usually hilarious. But
what if I told you that Mad Libs is not
just a silly childhood game and in fact
hidden in this game is everything you
need to start writing great sentences.
Now, to play great sentences Mad Libs,
you can use any sentence and I've
included 10 that you can start
practicing today in the free resource
linked down below the like button. But
to demonstrate it, I'm going to use a
poem from Lewis Carroll called
Jabberwocky. So, the original poem is
'Twas brillig and the slithy toves did
gyre and gimble in the wabe. All mimsy
were the borogoves and the mome raths
outgrabe. And so, to play this game, you
swap out those words for whatever words
you think would fit there. So, for
example, if we replace the word brillig,
what words could we put there? There are
tons of options. 'Twas cold, 'twas
early, 'twas Denmark. But there are
other words that definitely wouldn't
work there. 'Twas wood, 'twas the. Same
thing goes for the slithy toves. If we
wanted to replace that, we could write
the misty mountains, the colorful
balloons, the hungry wolves, the
shimmering stars. But there are other
words that just would not work. The
color balloons, the shimmer stars, the
colorful hungry, the misty shimmering.
That's the great thing about this
exercise. You don't need to know what
the grammar rules are. You know them
automatically, and just practicing with
them like this is enough. And just like
playing the piano scales, playing Mad
Libs like this is a great way to develop
your comfort with the forms that
underlie great sentences. Only it's
better than that because practicing with
forms like this isn't just mechanical
repetition like it is with the piano
scales. It actually produces new
sentences. And this is exactly what Don
DeLillo means when he says that being a
writer means being a sentence sculptor,
which is why he developed this technique
for writing. When I finish writing a
paragraph, he said, "even a three-line
paragraph, I automatically went to a
fresh page to start the new paragraph.
No crowded pages. This enabled me to see
a given set of sentences more clearly."
DeLillo understands that great writing
happens at the sentence level. But the
thing is, nobody buys tickets to
Carnegie Hall to listen to a musician
practice the scales. So, what do you do
when you develop your chops and you're
ready to move on to writing meaningful
content? Well, to make your meaning
stand out in a way that readers will
love, watch this video next because it's
going to show you four features of
reader psychology that you can use to
make your writing simple and clear,
which is the key to great writing. So,
be sure to go check it out.